big thank you to EA for sponsoring
today's video so as all great stories
worth telling begin a few days ago I was
scrolling through Tick Tock when I
suddenly stumbled across this video who
would have won the 25th World Martial
Arts Tournament if we actually got to
see it in its completion this is a great
idea for a video
what if Baba Dia Majin Buu never
interfered in the 25th
allowing it therefore to conclude as it
always was supposed to with Goku and
Vegeta in the first round now as you
know I don't typically do what if
scenarios on this channel and I don't
plan on doing any in the future either
but this question about the tournament
winner can be answered in two different
ways I think the first by keeping the
current Tournament standings we can use
power scaling and my own head Cannon to
arrive at an approximate conclusion
certainly one more accurate than that
Tick Tock I saw and second it offers me
a chance to get creative and try to
study just how Toriyama used to write
these tournament arcs back in the day
and in using what I've learned I will
propose my own 25th Tenkaichi Budokai
standings and results therein and hey
you guys can do the same at home post
who you think would win in the comments
down below this is gonna be fun let's
get the first one out of the way using
power scaling and my fan theories
exclusively how do I think this 25th
Tenkaichi budakai plays out well let's
see top 16. as you can see we've got a
lot of exciting matchups in the first
rounds but to jog your memories and lay
the groundwork for this I need to
mention a few things at the beginning
because bobbity and boo won't be
interfering with these matches neither
spotovich nor yamu are empowered by
Bobby's magic furthermore just like the
manga all the Saiyans agreed not to use
super saiyan in this tournament and just
like all the other tournaments from the
past ringouts forfeits and Knockouts are
the only ways to secure a victory in a
given matchup oh also for the sake of
Interest I'll be including the Supreme
Kai and kibito in this tournament while
Bobby and boo won't be interfering like
they did in the manga again for the sake
of Interest let's pretend that Supreme
Kai is there because he suspects that
there might be an attack midways through
the tournament but instead it happens at
the end because Bobby wants the
strongest one or something I don't know
keeping all that in mind the first two
fights of this round go pretty much
exactly like they did the manga Krillin
defeats pintar because of course he does
and shin defeats Piccolo via forfeit now
that doesn't decision might seem weird
to Piccolo fans but it's actually not as
simple as you might think and so before
I went forward with my decision I
decided to take a poll asking you guys
on Twitter which character was stronger
and the results were rather split albeit
slightly still in the favor of Piccolo
however with that said both the English
and Japanese translations of the manga
tell a very different story in the
English translation of the manga it
reads almost as if Piccolo forfeited out
of respect or reverence for the Supreme
Kai's rank with Supreme Kai noting that
kame might have contributed to that call
and Piccolo later saying that he was and
I quote a different order of being the
Japanese translation of that scene
however more directly translates to our
dimensions are just too different this
same wording can be seen in many
different places in the manga like when
ten shinan spoke about Super Saiyan Goku
or when the narrator described final
form Frieza this is all to say I would
hedge my bets on Piccolo being weaker
than Shin in addition to any other
argument I might have Shin takes the
victory here alright and with that out
of the way time to move on to some new
stuff the Dell versus switch this is the
spot where the tournament derails and
ultimately stops being the focus of the
story in the original continuity of the
manga up until now everything has been
going the same way as it did in the
manga but this is where things changed
given that spokovic wasn't seen as
anything special prior to Bobby's
magical power boost Fidel being a gifted
fighter in her own right and as well
being armed with her new foundability of
flight easily overcomes Popovich for the
win and advances alongside shin and
Krillin into the quarterfinals kibito vs
Gohan kibito certainly is one of the
most characters of all time but even if
we ignore that glowing endorsement I
just gave him I don't know if he can
stand up to Gohan for this one so I'm
just going to give this round to Gohan I
think he's clearly the stronger of the
two Android 18 vs Mr shape alright so
this is where I might make some fans or
enemies depending on which of these
characters you are a fan of I think 18
easily takes this round now I could hear
some folks complaining but Mr Satan
would bribe her this would be true if he
had any idea how strong she was to begin
with the only reason Mr Satan knew he
would need to bribe her in the first
place was because he saw what she was
capable of after the tournament evolved
into a battle royale and given that he's
now going into this fight with an unjust
level of confidence he won't think to
bribe her right away and with one punch
the no-nonsense Android 18 casually
walks her way to the quarterfinals The
Crowd Goes Wild the former champ is
knocked out in the first round Goku vs
Vegeta I'm a massive fan of both of
these characters and despite Goku being
my favorite character in the series I
still think that this fight could really
go either way both Fighters had been
tirelessly training for the last several
years however I still think that Goku
edges out the victory here because his
ghost body is slightly more resilient
than Vegeta's mortal one plus it's more
thematically interesting heading towards
the quarterfinals Goku is after all the
only character remaining now with a
prior World Martial Arts Tournament to
win Mighty mask vs Killer I don't really
know what else to say here money Mass
takes a killer with no questions asked
moving on yamu vs Jewel
um I don't know uh flip a coin Jewel
wins against yanu okay move on to the
quarterfinals now quarterfinals now that
we're in the quarterfinals we have some
really weird matchups so let's see how
they Shape Up Krillin vs the Supreme Kai
I don't think it's unreasonable to
suggest that this is where Krillin bows
out of the tournament for good uh Shin
will be way too much for him and will
advance into the semi-finals Videl vs
Gohan I think this is a really cute
match to take place and one I was
surprised is wasn't actually in the
original manga for any amount of time it
would have been a really nice callback
to Goku's matchup against Chichi in the
23rd Tenkaichi Budokai but regardless
Videl takes the loss here while Gohan
dressed as the great Sandman marches
onward towards the semi-finals Android
18 vs Goku Android 18 vs Goku is a
really interesting one now that I'm
looking at it more closely when you take
away the speed and power boost of Super
Saiyan from the equation for me at least
this is a rather difficult thing to
quantify and so I decided to go with
battle experience instead if there's
anything that Goku's proven in this
series is that he's an extremely
difficult person to eliminate from a
tournament I mean ask Piccolo overall I
think Goku's battle IQ is high enough
such that it finds a way to squeak out a
victory by way of ring out here before
the stamina that he has becomes an issue
against Android 18. Goku advances the
semi-finals Mighty mask vs Jewel
um jeez Goten and Trunks are really
getting the easiest road to the finals
here despite being ridiculously clumsy
and almost falling out themselves on
more than one occasion Mighty mask once
again takes the victory three and moves
on to the semi-finals the semi-finals
Gohan vs the Supreme Kai so this one was
another tricky one to come to a
conclusion on but in the end we decided
that Shin would ultimately fall to Gohan
in this encounter it's a close match and
it really could go either way depending
on who you're talking to but from what
we were able to glean base Gohan is a
bit weaker than base Vegeta and shin is
very strong in his own right however
when they're in babidi's ship and Pui
Pui comes out to fight Vegeta it's
pretty obvious or implied that it would
be a very tough fight for shin however
not so much the case for Vegeta at all
according to Goku and later demonstrated
by Vegeta himself I think this alone is
enough to establish the fact that while
the Supreme Kai Shin is much stronger
than most people give him credit for
there's still at least enough of a
disparity between him and the base
Saiyans for us to plausibly give Gohan
the W here Goku vs Mighty mask look we
all knew Mighty Mass lucky streak of
opponents would have to come to an end
and my god do they come to a screech
halt with this one Goten and trunk so
far in this tournament have found
themselves squaring up against some of
the easiest competition but right now
they are squaring up against possibly
the most powerful fighter in the
universe and needless to say they lose
Goku barely needs to try and for the
fourth time in his martial arts career
Goku finds himself moving into the
finals to meet his son but before we
move on to the finals to see who's
really the best of the best I want to
take a moment to talk about another
venture into the wild to see who's
really the strongest of them all in EA's
brand new game wild Hearts this unique
take on the hunting genre sees you
jumping into this insanely stunning
fantasy woven take on fuel Japan to take
down kimono crazy powerful beasts that
have fused with their environment and
evolved to use these Powers against you
they come in all different shapes and
sizes and if you're familiar with
Japanese mythology at all you'll
definitely see some familiar faces here
Amaterasu rage tail King Tusk there are
so many creatures and it's so
interesting to see which one's abilities
challenge your specific play style the
most and that is because hunting them
down actually offers up a pretty pretty
crazy amount of variety here not only do
you have eight different weapons to
choose from that offer a distinctly
different play style like the Smashing
mall or the Finesse fueled wagasa you'll
also be able to dynamically construct
crazy ancient Tech in the midst of
battle to get the jump on your opponent
the game is insanely intense in Solo
play and yet it offers you the ability
to play with two others online so you
can expand your coordination to take on
special missions you can download wild
Hearts today using the link in the
description and if you get the chance
come back to this video and leave a
comment letting me know how you think
each monster Stacks up against each
other
Gohan vs Goku Gohan vs Goku is a
surprisingly perfect way to end this
tournament that was never designed to
have a conclusion in the first place
there's a wonderful sense of coming full
circle with this one but I think given
that we have to be ruthlessly logical
here and not account for any sort of
story Nuance Goku has to take the
victory here without question he's just
far too experienced powerful still in
his prime and has the added benefit of
being more resilient thanks to him being
dead and all and so looking at this from
a power scouting point of view Goku
emerges from the 25th Tenkaichi Budokai
as the world champion making him a
two-time champion and proving that even
when dead there's no escape from Goku's
dominating performances at the World
Martial Arts tournaments or is there
while this was a fun little exercise to
play scorekeeper with the fact remains
that if Toriyama wanted to ride a
tournament with this roster of
characters it would have been structured
and looked and played out nothing like
this in my review of The Original Dragon
Ball series I spoke about the
overarching story lines that Toriyama
would interweave into the narrative to
guide us through these tournaments in
both a fulfilling and satisfying fashion
offering each character their own goals
and mini stories within which we could
enjoy on our way to the big finish that
he had orchestrated and planned and so
armed with this information and this new
approach here's how I think this roster
of characters could be written into
toriyama's tournament for the Buu saga
if he intended on presenting us with a
winner toriyama's tournament Akira
Toriyama helped to popularize the quote
tournament Arc we all know and love
today all the way back in the 1980s
after Dragon Ball's first ever are
concluded amongst readers there was a
feeling that since the Dragon Balls had
been gathered once before and the Dragon
released they had seen all of what
dragon Ball's story had to offer and
according to toriyama's editor at the
time this resulted in a minor lowland
popularity for the series due to this
pressure Akira Toriyama decided to
implement what we all now know today as
the tournament Arc immediately this
brought in a massive amount of interest
and due to that success Austrian a flood
of tournament arcs during that time
period for other series and thereafter
famously hirohiko araki author of JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure mentions in his book
manga in theory in practice that during
appeared in which his career was
experiencing a bit of a lull too the
Publishers and editors he was working
with encouraged him too to incorporate a
tournament Arc to draw in more readers
because it was that successful araki
however did deny to follow the trend
because he's a digger chat that hates
his own trail but the fact that this
happened at all I think speaks volumes
to how effective and prolific this story
structure became and looking at it from
the outside in I can see why we might
not fully recognize internally why we
feel certain ways about certain settings
or scenarios in TV and film but have you
ever wondered why so many stories in the
west and the East are set in schools
there are of course many reasons but
primarily it's a setting that doesn't
require Exposition and explanation for
how it works we've all been to one and
had experiences there ourselves and as a
result now know what to expect and might
even find connection to familiar
elements implemented in the story
because of the setting this is a
long-winded way of me saying that we
like this setting because it doesn't
challenge us to understand it it's
familiar and therefore comfortable
tournaments are similar in this regard
similar to top 10 videos with a
tournament we know what we're roughly
getting in for structurally there's
going to be a group of characters some
familiar some not and an antagonist that
our heroes try to defeat in the end
that's generally and generically how it
works with our protagonists pushing
himself to overcome literal challenges
on the road to the finals it's simple we
know what to expect and it's comfortable
and as a result Akira Toriyama struck
gold with this decision not just because
of all the benefits this setting offers
but when it came to a fighting manga it
was the perfect setting to streamline
his storytelling process in a believable
fashion which brings me to his approach
to writing a tournament Arc a large
component of what makes these Dragon
Ball World tournaments successful is
toriyama's dedication to telling a story
and lucky for us we can look at three
separate World Martial Arts tournaments
he's written and the first thing I
noticed while reading through these to
study is that these arcs aren't fun
because they're a series of fights I
mean we don't even really need a
tournament for that really it's more so
the story that follows along with the
setting of the tournament itself for
instance you might think looking at the
21st Tenkaichi Budokai in Dragon Ball
the first tournament of the series that
the goal of the arc is for Goku to win
the tournament and while we as readers
might be following and hoping that Goku
pulls out the victory here the story
that's actually being told is the
opposite in that story Goku had been
established as a great fighter and fully
capable of winning the entire tournament
before it even began and because of this
such an easy Victory might cause Goku to
feel complacent like he doesn't need to
train or better himself if he does win
and so roshi instead makes it his goal
and indeed the goal of the arc itself to
ensure that Goku doesn't win to make
sure he learns the necessary lessons
required of him to become the guardian
of Earth one day and this approach to
storytelling is on its own an
explanation for why power scaling really
doesn't matter all that much and what
folks should really be paying attention
to if they want to predict the ending of
a fight is the narrative direction of
the series and due to this approach with
Goku established early on in the 21st
Tenkaichi Budokai every subsequent
tournament in early Dragon Ball becomes
not a question of will Goku win the
tournament but instead is Goku ready to
win the tournament yet it's a small
difference but once understood the
battles he undergoes in these
competitions suddenly feel that much
more weighty particularly when you take
into consideration the response ability
a title like world's champion bestows
onto you it's the key difference between
Sport and fiction while set in a
sporting type setting the dragon ball
tournaments are there not to necessarily
show us who has the biggest power level
mine's pretty big but instead to tell us
a captivating story across a series of
fights to explore the intangibles that
can't be captured in numbers like
tenacity determination and humbleness
and when Goku does eventually win later
in the series against Piccolo he does so
fittingly by saving the world at the
exact same time proving that to be the
world champion he did indeed too need to
become the defender of the earth and so
that final battle in the 23rd Tenkaichi
Budokai isn't just the climax of The Ark
itself but stands also as a culmination
of three separate tournaments worth of
Storytelling having arrived at a very
specific point in time and that's just
looking at the main character of the
series along with this there were always
subplots that either didn't feed into or
intentionally fit into the main plot in
their own rights while also allowing The
Supporting Cast members to do just as
they were designed to support keeping
all of this in mind I will now attempt
to for fun try and guess how the 25th
Tenkai Budokai could have played out if
there was a plan to bring it to
completion this is an alternate timeline
alternate reality where I'm trying to
figure out what could be a plausible way
this tournament could have ended with
these characters naturally once again
this is only for fun and not to be taken
too seriously and if you want to try it
yourself in the comments down below or
even in your own video I highly
encourage others to get creative with me
on this because it's really fun
with that out of the way let's begin
broadly speaking we think the most
important aspect of this attempted
rewrite of the 25th Tenkaichi Budokai
section will be our finding of a way of
telling a compelling overarching story
that manages to tie in all the
characters in some sort of cohesive
fashion one character in particular made
this excessively difficult but we'll get
to that in just a second in the interest
of authenticity we've decided to allow
the lead up to this tournament that was
originally in the manga and the real
world to inform the direction this story
we're telling is going to take this
means we won't be trying to make up
character arcs for characters but
instead we'll be reformatting this
tournament such that it reaches its
conclusion while still facilitating a
lot of the things we enjoy about the two
Saga itself later on and so following
Goku's sacrifice in the Cell Games Akira
Toriyama decided he wanted to keep Goku
dead and after the time skip that
followed wish for Gohan to lead the
series as the main protagonist as we all
know this creative decision on behalf of
Akira Toriyama changed as he later
admitted Gohan wasn't suited for the
role which led him to reverse his
decision on Goku's future thus bringing
him back into the story for the
tournament and the events of the Buu
saga and the moment Goku returns is the
moment we are starting this retelling I
want to have this Prelude to the
tournament emphasize the passage of time
since Goku's last win at the 23rd
Tenkaichi Budokai it's been many years
many battles later and he's been dead
for quite some time a large part of the
bu Saga sees Goku concerned with and
focused on fostering the talent for the
Next Generation so with this retelling I
want to try to lean into that and to
kick things off I wanted to do something
kind of cute when Goku arrived at the
23rd Tenkaichi Budokai no one recognized
him because he had grown so much and I
like the idea of that being contrasted
here with everyone surrounding him
delighted to see him specifically but
also maybe have Gohan approach him too
this time Goku is the one not to
recognize his own son with how much he's
changed while being in his Saiyan man
head wrap I think that would be a nice
and cute nod to the 23rd Tenkaichi
Budokai and a fun way to reintroduce two
beloved characters also I know it's
anime only but I love the first
interaction between Goku and Goten so so
that's going in there too also all the
prior tournaments have had Goku was the
main player and while this one will be
no different instead of looking at his
own future he's going to be the one
looking at his son's future naturally we
have the same players in this tournament
Mr Satan returning as the champ Videl
shin and kibito participating because
they believe babadi will attack the
tournament at some point Goku Gohan
Mighty mask AKA Trunks and Goten Piccolo
Krillin Android 18 Vegeta and of course
some lesser Fighters like Jewel Killa
yamu spapovic and Pinter as the fighters
rated themselves they start to draw the
lots for the brackets Mr Satan as the
returning champ draws first putting on a
brave face he steadies his hand as it
shakes into the box and draws out number
14. next up is Videl who draws number
16. Berlin draws number three killer
draws two Jewel six and Vegeta 5. Gohan
is next up and draws number seven
followed by Shin who draws number eight
and smiles at Gohan wishing him luck
Mighty mask almost tripping over his own
own costume collects number 11 kibito
draws Lot number 12 right after without
so much as a single sign of nerves yamu
draws number 13 taking a big gulp as he
dreads taking on the reigning champ in
the first round slopovich laughs and
reaches in and collects number 15 he
begins to confidently Snicker in the
direction of the Dell just because your
dad's champ doesn't mean you're getting
special treatment okay Adele responds
with good pintire draws number nine and
immediately following that Android 18
draws number 10. pintar complains
booishly and wishes he got a more
intimidating opponent Krillin quickly
equips back and says buddy you have no
idea what you're in for a deep voice
cuts through the air as he says this
neither do you Krillin turns around and
sees that Piccolo is holding Lot Number
Four he takes a big gulp and before he
can say anything Goku Pats him on the
back and says oh man I'm jealous I hope
I get someone good Krillin looking at
Goku confused says but there's only one
ball left Goku enthusiastically reaches
it and collects Lot number one and with
that the stage is set the Saiyans have
all agreed not to use their Super Saiyan
4 terms and with that the first match is
set to begin
top 16.
Goku vs Kila the point of this and
indeed the Vegeta fight later during
this first round is to highlight the
frimer mind and energy both he and Goku
are bringing to this tournament Goku Bao
showing humility and Readiness to not
hurt or humiliate and once the Bell does
ring comfortably advances to the next
round without issue by quickly and
gently knocking killer out of bounds
Goku strolls off the Arena Stage and
wishes both Krillin and Piccolo good
luck in their next match nervously
Krillin takes a big breath and walks out
to the center of the Ring Krillin vs
Piccolo this is the first big fight of
the tournament and one of the highlights
early on for sure as a nice rematch to
their intense bout prior to Z Krillin is
faced with the question of whether or
not he has what it takes to still hang
with those big names anymore perhaps
he's too old perhaps he's gotten too
comfortable and while the fight begins
extremely one-sided with Krillin not
putting up the same level of competition
he did during the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai
once he hears his daughter cheering for
him in the stands and looks back to see
his wife watching the fight he manages
to cam himself and form a strategy this
is where through some quick thinking
Piccolo was taken by surprise and put on
the back foot in this fight Krillin
pushes Piccolo further than he ever
thought he could be capable of as Marin
cheers on her dad 18 joins the chorus as
Krillin comes within an inch of knocking
the namekian out of bounds watching this
fight Shin looks at kabito concerned he
utters just who are these people in the
end however it's not enough and Piccolo
manages to take the win despite
sustaining a decent amount of damage
unlike their first match this time
Piccolo helps Krillin up off the floor
and together they walk back to the
waiting area together where Goku
congratulates both of them he says to
Krillin that he really hasn't lost a
step and must have been training hard
since they last saw each other Krillin
cracks a bashful Smile as 18 is
delighted he put on such an amazing
performance as this joyful interaction
transpires on his way to the ring walks
Vegeta straight past Goku without so
much as a single word or glance Vegeta
vs Jewel unlike Goku's fight against
Kila this contest has similar energy to
that of Vegeta versus the punching
machine Vegeta has absolutely zero
interest in fighting this fool he'd get
more competition from staring at his own
reflection in an even shorter amount of
time Vegeta embarrasses and steamrolls
this nobody without so much as a second
thought for his safety advancing to the
quarterfinals in dominant fashion as
Vegito walks off the stage Goku notices
that Piccolo has been staring at Shin
quite a lot 18 vs pintar similarly to
how Krillin took out pintar in the
original continuity 18 does so here in
just as dominant to Fashion pintar
idiotically boasts about how he isn't
afraid to fight a woman or something but
that he'll be sure not to hold back 18
Cammy responds I wouldn't stress about
it before landing one lightning fast
attack knocking him unconscious as the
fight itself is finishing up and both
Fighters make their ways off the stage
Goku and Piccolo tell Gohan not to take
this Shin guy lightly his match with
Gohan is next and that something strange
is going on and that he should keep his
guard up Gohan vs Shin as the match
begins Gohan immediately follows his
father and Piccolo's guidance by putting
up his guard Shin Smiles asking Gohan
are you strong like those other Fighters
are you the son of the one called Goku
we've been keeping a close watch and are
very impressed in response Gohan begins
performing his great Sandman stick and
denies his relation to Goku but quickly
returns to his full fighting guide ready
for the first attack as opening contest
goes this one could be argued either way
strengthwise narratively this acts as
the initial shock point for Gohan's
character who wasn't expected to be
given any trouble at all until he faced
either his dad Piccolo or Vegeta on more
than one occasion Gohan is almost
eliminated the fact that he's up against
the ropes not by one of his powerful
friends but by an unknown tournament
contestant really concerns Gohan he
knows he's not as strong as he was
against cell but has he Fallen further
than he thought in the end Gohan's
strength just manages to scrape out of
Victory for him after sustaining a
non-insignificant amount of damage from
shin and his bizarre abilities Goku
congratulates his son but says that if
he doesn't look out he might just be out
of this contest before long he says this
looking at Shin who is seen Whispering
something into kibito's ear following
this kabido quits before his match can
even begin as a result the next matches
can and mighty mask AKA Goten and Trunks
Advanced to the quarterfinals without so
much as a single fight next up Satan vs
yam Satan is relieved for now with his
positioning as I mentioned earlier both
yamu and spokovic don't have Bobby's
magic hair and are just normal Fighters
and so yamu is well within Satan's
capabilities but at the same time Satan
realizes that it's only a matter of time
before he has to go up against one of
these demigods in the later rounds if he
doesn't figure a way out of this but the
question is how is he going to get out
of this without hurting his image
needless to say he manages to take out
Gamu without much trouble at all Krillin
even makes a complimentary remark about
his ability saying and I quote at least
he's not a total fraud which is nice
standing Victorious Satan boasts and
poses to his adoring fans after his win
all the while in his mind he is still
thinking just how screwed he actually is
the Dell vs Popovich given what happened
to Videl in the original manga I wanted
to have this match to close out the
first round and restore balance to the
universe in the original manga Videl was
wrecking spuppovich to the point people
thought he died that is before Bobby's
magic kicked in and he brutalized Videl
thanks to the performance enhancement in
this version of events however he has
absolutely no chance forcing Mr Satan to
look on as his daughter demonstrates
incredible Feats even he can't do and as
Videl knocks out spokovic and the
referee's count reaches 10 declaring
Videl the winner Satan looks at the
brackets and sees that his next opponent
is his now very game daughter as the
minutes begin counting down to the
opening bout of the quarterfinals Goku
prepares by limbering up and stretching
he shouts over to Piccolo to not go easy
on him he says that this body might be
new but he still has a lot of his old
tricks up his sleeve so he hopes the
piccolo will be ready to give him
everything he's got just like last time
Gohan completely blown away by what he's
just heard starts to verbally question
if his dad really will go all out to
which Piccolo replies I've known your
father for a long time Gohan and I've
never known him to be a liar but don't
you for a second think that he's been
the the only one preparing for the next
big fight Gohan perplex looks up to
Piccolo but his attention is elsewhere
the two fighters Goku and Piccolo
staring at each other Sherry silent but
competitive nod of mutual respect before
one by one making their ways to The
Arena Stage the corner finals begins now
Goku vs Piccolo standing before Goku as
he bows Piccolo remarks that since his
student is watching closely he can
afford to take things slowly from the
start he says if it's all right with you
Goku I'd like to cut to the chase taking
off his weighted clothing dropping it to
the ring floor crushing the tiles
beneath Goku replies with a smile
looking over to Gohan way ahead of you
Piccolo it's not like I got time to be
wasted assuming new fighting stances for
but a fleeting moment both Fighters
explode into action exchanging and
dodging their respective attacks the win
from The Clash is fierce while Gohan
looks on in all of their abilities Mr
Satan is terrified blown to the back of
the room where Vegeta looks on with an
impatient skull painted across his Stern
face both Goku and Piccolo know just how
far each of them have come since they
last met in the world tournament base
form Goku vs Pink is a competitive
matchup like Goku Piccolo has been
training and won't be caught by the same
traps Goku offered in the 23rd Tenkaichi
Budokai he might even specifically bait
Goku into trying similar techniques only
to provide a quick and damaging counter
offensive as Goku quickly adapts to the
situation as only he can Piccolo's
strategy and tenacity is noted using old
techniques to Goat out the predictable
response from Goku who on more than one
occasion almost falls out of bounds due
to the clever planning of the namekian
however Goku's battle IQ is off the
chart and is able to outperform Piccolo
in the end for a decisive win some
damage has been sustained but as he's
helping Piccolo up he remarks jeez
Piccolo you almost had me there you've
become so much more powerful since we
last saw each other you're almost like a
different person the crowd applaud the
sportsmanship between the two fighters
as they make their ways back to the
waiting area but before they even make
it to the back Vegeta approaches on his
way to the ring Goku quickly wishes him
luck it's the first time either have
engaged with one another since the Cell
Games to which Vegeta responds by
telling Goku to keep his concerns and
advice to himself focus on the fight to
come Kakarot I assure are you you'll
need it Vegeta walks past the two
fighters with conviction followed close
behind by Android 18. it's time for
another rematch Vegeta vs Android 18.
this is a rematch I know Millions would
love to see myself included Vegeta vs
Android 18 was one of my favorite fights
from the early Android Saga and even
here it provides a very different flavor
of battle to what came before with
Piccolo and Goku unlike that fight which
was all action and respect this one has
a little bit more posturing and talking
and not to mention sort of a grudge
match all the sort of things we love
from Vegeta it's clear to see that he
still carries with in The Grudge all
these years later and teasingly hopes
that 18 doesn't mind him not taking it
easy on her to which she responds now
doesn't that attitude sound familiar the
announcer Begins the match and with a
crooked smile Vegeta Launches on the
offensive this is another competitive
fight one that 18 never thought it would
be given the self-imposed handicapped
Vegeta and the other Saiyans have
implemented this is the moment we see
Vegeta has been training ruthlessly
obsessively and tirelessly for years
he's improved a terrifying amount and no
matter what she does Vegeta always seems
to get right back 18 is impressed with
Vegeta's tenacity but says that at this
rate Vegeta will run out of energy if he
doesn't figure out a way to overcome the
speed difference that it's now a war of
attrition similar to the first fight
Vegeta says that if she's planning on
relying on that same cheap and cowardly
strategy she's more idiotic than she
looks he's not going to be making that
same mistake twice because Vegeta is not
relying on or using Super Saiyan his
energy reserves are far more enduring
than 18 experience with the Super Saiyan
form and just like Goku Vegeta is a born
warrior with Decades of experience and
all he has to do is wait for that
perfect opening while 18 is a fantastic
fighter in her own right Vegeta is on
another level altogether and through
setting some clever traps he puts her
away before her Infinite Energy becomes
a problem for him a second time Goku
congratulates him Vegeta scoffs glaring
at Goku with the smile and advances to
the semi-finals Gohan vs Mighty mask
this is another fight that is
surprisingly close for Gohan once again
to his surprise Gohan is definitely
stronger than both Goten and Trunks
individually but the two of them
together might actually beat him without
any transforming their detriment however
is that they are all crammed inside a
single stupid outfit and so can fight to
quite their full potential needless to
say Gohan recognizes the two boys under
the suit and takes full advantage of it
confusing them causing an argument which
buys him enough time to send them out of
the ring but again despite coming away
with the victory he is faced with a much
tougher fight than he had ever
anticipated even if it was against two
young individuals he had remarked before
the tournament that if he wasn't careful
Goten might catch up to him in terms of
strength but having that notion nearly
come to fruition right in front of you
is a whole different story as he makes
his way back into the waiting area Satan
is seen bargaining with his daughter who
is up next to fight he asks her if she's
sure she wants to fight her own father
knowing full while he stands no chance
against her as she is and insulted by
this Videl ignores his efforts and
insists they go to the ring right now
sweating intensely and with his mind
racing Satan follows apprehensively to
the center of the Ring Hamming it up to
the crowd through a fake facade of
confidence
Satan versus Videl after seeing Piccolo
vs Goku Vegeta vs 18 and Gohan vs Mighty
mask Satan frantically begins to scour
his mind for a way out any way out how
could he possibly be stuck in this
competition with all of these monsters
he thinks he's even seen Videl fight in
her match against Popovich and she's
even giving him cause for concern he
seemingly has no way out looking across
of Adele she readies herself for attack
and just as he's about to open his mouth
he has an idea the bell rings and Videl
races forward for a big attack however
before she makes contact with Mr Satan
he follows the floor looking soccer
player in agony looking for a penalty
kick in the Box rolling around the floor
almost sarcastically it slowly becomes
obvious to the crowd watching that
something's not right here as soon as
Vidal is announced the winner Mr Satan
Springs to his feet like a bunny and
Embraces his daughter raising her hand
for the crowd of confused fans like I'd
ever hurt my little girl she's the
future after all the announcer's voice
Rings through the arena what a selfless
savior or Mr Satan is his love
admiration for his own daughter always
the conviction he has to reclaim a
material desire like the world title
what what hero the crowd erupts with
cheers and very soon the spotlight
shifts from Videl to Mr Satan as he has
whistled away on a river of reporters
out the door and away from all the other
competitors no doubt to continue to spin
the narrative he is contrived Vidal is
left confused with her hands hanging in
the ring by her side insulted and angry
she matches to the back she advances to
the semi-finals begrudgingly the
semi-finals following his fight with
Gohan Goten runs to his dad apologizing
for entering but excitedly asks how he
thought he did Goku offers him praise a
warm laugh and most importantly promises
not to tell Chichi seeing this trunks
looks over to Vegeta scared to approach
him the same Prince walking past his son
locks eyes with Goku as he makes his way
to the ring he shouts Kakarot it's time
Goku vs Vegeta as Goku follows closely
behind the chatter in the waiting area
grinds to a halt worried they all know
that this out of all the fights could be
the one that gets the most carried away
as the two fighters face off assuming
their classic poses it's time for the
rematch to end all rematches Goku vs
Vegeta the announcer screams begin
immediately the two fighters disappear
as they Clash all around the arena this
is another one of those classic fights
from the series where two Rivals get to
Duke it out and see who the best really
is and sticking to the rules they set
neither one uses any other Super Saiyan
Transformations there's plenty of banter
back and forth however I really wanted
to eventually swing in Goku's favor due
to his otherworldly body offering some
sort of minor advantage that Vegeta's
normal one doesn't have this idea is
exploring the manga towards the very end
of the Buu saga where Goku can seem to
charge up enough energy in his Super
Saiyan 3 form and I kind of want to
extrapolate on that idea it might not be
directly analogous but I'm going to use
it for this particular purpose here and
after a quick exchange that Vegeta
doesn't quite get the better of he sent
falling for out of bounds before
reactively igniting his Super Saiyan
form after this he drops to the floor
and without looking back understands why
he lost and acknowledges to no one he
didn't win but this wasn't the fair
fight he wanted this offers Vegeta an
excuse to protect his pride on the
surface at least and allows Goku to pick
up the win and Advance onto the finals
the Dell vs Gohan Gohan versus Vidal is
too perfect a match of not to have in
this contest and while it acts as a nice
callback to Goku vs Chichi from the 2013
kaichi budakai this match itself plays
out rather differently and following
that complete sign of disrespect from
her father the Dell is eager to work out
that anger in this fight and unlike his
father Gohan isn't so innocent and
oblivious to what he needs to do here
for a solid minute after the Bell Rings
he Dodges and tries to avoid hurting her
and through doing so almost loses his
disguise on more than one occasion the
angle I'd like to go with on this one is
for Gohan to be not willing to make the
difficult decision by showing her the
respect she deserves as a fighter and
from that point Fidel lands some big
hits on Gohan and during this creative
action really well owes the crowd in her
favor she even manages to defend Gohan's
tame attempts to knock her out of bounds
by flying eventually however Gohan does
need to get the win here in a quick
flash of light She's Out of Bounds
before feeling a single thing say a man
is declared the winner and moves on to
the finals Goku vs Gohan I want this
fight to be Goku's opportunity to Mentor
His Son Gohan in a similar fashion to
roshi during the 21st Tenkaichi Budokai
this is Goku's attempt to combat the
complacent nature of Gohan to not
discourage him from pursuing what he
wants to do through his studies and the
great Sandman but to keep up his
training in an effort to ensure he can
be responsible for the world and those
he leaves behind he explains that he
needed to be the person who saved the
world once before and that perhaps
someday another foe might emerge that
will require Gohan to take similar
action against and that there will come
a day where he Goku can't bail him out
if he makes a mistake again Akira
Toriyama wanted to bring Goku back into
the story because he felt Gohan didn't
fit in the main character role and I
think that makes sense for the story he
was trying to tell and so with this
angle in mind I'm allowing Gohan the
chance to return to a pupil position
while Goku is once again leading the
charge with him now accepting the role
roshi had towards the beginning of the
series keeping all of this in mind in an
effort to push Gohan and to bring the
most out of him Goku says that for this
fight he'd like to lift the moratorium
on Transformations and with that
explodes into Super Saiyan 2. this is
the fight however that pushes Vegeta
over the edge as he looks on in this
fight while Goku allows Gohan to go all
out in order to deal with his son's
pressure at the height of the contest
for a split second Goku shows a flash of
something more than any of them have
ever seen before not many would notice
but Vegeta certainly did and it's enough
to send him into a spiral flying off
this Gap that exists between him and
Goku now is far more than what could be
explained Away by a simple otherworldly
body he's trained tirelessly for years
and the only thing he has to show for it
is a wider Gap than there was before
it's humiliating and his ego cannot take
it as Gohan staggers before Goku
bordering and falling unconscious from
his lack of energy Goku says to Gohan
I'm proud of you son but you need to
keep working hard you need to know who
could be out there there's always going
to be someone stronger which is why we
need to keep training Gohan doesn't
respond but smiles and with that lunges
One Last Time towards his father his
Aura bursting like a bubble around him
before he can land the final hit he
falls into his father's arms I really
enjoyed that exchange Goku and Gohan had
in Dragon Ball super leading up to the
tournament of power and I kind of want
to mirror that here the referee checks
out Gohan and Goku is declared the
winner of the 25th Tenkaichi budakai I
like this line of Direction because it
highlights the difference between Goku
and Gohan quite well while also
recycling the best piece of tutelage
Goku ever received as a child one that
is also precisely what Gohan needed to
accept in his life moving forward but
how this piece of advice is received by
those two characters highlights their
differences immediately when Goku hears
that there are stronger Fighters around
every corner he gets excited for the
potential competition and prepares such
when Gohan hears it however he feels
compelled to train just in case
something bad happens a sense of
responsibility to those that can't
defend themselves this too feeds into
his superhero element of the great
Sandman character I think the ending a
very tired Goku helps to bring his even
more bruised and battered Son Gohan back
to Consciousness Goku is announced the
winner of the 25th Tenkaichi Budokai
when suddenly everyone in the arena
falls to the floor unconscious as barely
visible images of a mysterious figure
Flash in and out of the tournament
grounds cameraman and all fall pointing
their cameras to the sky in the middle
of the Ring they both sense some things
not right the others in the back their
energies are fading they hear screams
before suddenly Goku falls to the floor
too totally Zapped of energy barely
conscious and Confused Gohan hears Videl
scream Gohan's anger pushes him to his
feet and Goku shouts at him not to do
anything stupid that they need to
strategize Gohan ignores him and
stumbles himself to the back dragging
himself after his Son Goku follows where
together they see that Fidel is gone
along with some of the others Gohan
explodes with even more power he senses
those responsible that are fleeing in
the distance and just about manages to
fly after them Goku doesn't have enough
energy to stop him having just finished
talking with the Press outside so Satan
wanders back and doesn't hear or see
anyone he pokes his head outside to the
arena and again hears and sees everyone
in the arena on the floor he sheepishly
wanders out to see what's going on when
suddenly a cameraman comes to pointing
the camera into the center of the Ring
he says what just happened everyone in
the arena suddenly collapsed Mr Satan do
you have any insight into what just
transpired it is at this point Satan
pauses realizes the opportunity that's
Fallen onto his lap and then starts to
spew a whole bunch of his usual nonsense
he boasts that some evil doer swooped
into the premises and that he took quick
care of him however he does also add
that that still wouldn't have saved them
from falling asleep thanks to all of
these lackluster contests that have
transpired since he bowed out after this
you can cue a whole bunch of flexing and
The Crowd Goes Wild conclusion there
were a whole bunch of alternative routes
we could have taken this tournament in
we discussed countless Ways by which
Satan would win we talked about Satan
losing in the first round we had
numerous ways for Goku and Gohan to win
and even had a version where Vegeta
might have won if we wanted to lean into
the evil Vegeta thing even more in this
section but in the end I went went with
this for the following reasons I chose
to eliminate Satan early on for one
primary reason him winning the
tournament sort of adds this layer of
predictability that kind of ruins the
atmosphere it's an easy joke to make and
by virtue of that trying to make Satan
win we had to basically cram in all the
best fighters into only one half of the
table furthermore we've seen that Satan
has been filmed failing and clearly has
been bested on more than one occasion
the gag with Satan isn't so much that he
always wins necessarily but that he can
always convince everyone that he's a
winner despite the reality of the
situation and so when the idea was
pitched to have him cartoonishly and
intentionally lose to his daughter to
make himself look Noble we were Off to
the Races not only did it offer him a
way out but it gave him something to do
by talking to the press for the rest of
the tournament while also playing into
the fostering the Next Generation type
theme that this Arc was going for albeit
in a selfish way as you might have also
noticed the main plot of the tournament
was Goku and Gohan's student teacher
relationship with Goku reliving the past
from the beginning through Gohan's head
wrap to Piccolo vs Krillin to 18 vs
Vegeta all the way to his inevitable
rematch against the principal Saiyans in
this tournament Goku is reminded that
time is always passing and that now is
the time to instill the teachings his
mentor gave him to his own Son Gohan
despite being too polar opposite
individuals in many respects what I like
about this angle is that the advice
roshi gives to Goku is as relevant to
Gohan as it was to Goku and while both
received that message in different ways
both react to it in the same appropriate
fashion by preparing and training Goku
For the Love of competition and Gohan
for the love he has for others to
protect them it's one of dragon Ball's
core lessons and for that reason I think
it fits perfectly into this centerpiece
of a small tournament that is until
Deborah shows up and connects the Antics
from the contest themselves to the Buu
saga proper and in the process makes
good on the hints and build up the
Supreme Kai and kabito were therefore in
the first place one of the main things I
wanted to make sure happened however was
that the main character title of the
series returned back to Goku as that was
toriyama's goal once he brought him back
to life this offered Gohan the chance to
drop down a smidge but I didn't want to
lose track of him entirely he's still
best suited to a reactionary role and I
thought the Videl was a great vehicle
that offered Gohan the chance to make
the same mistake Goku made during the
22nd Tenkaichi Budokai following
tambourine's killing of Krillin you
might be concerned that such a choice
would produce a similar outcome and
while that might be true depending on
how you took the story from this point
on after the tournament I think Goku and
Gohan are different enough that a
compelling and distinct story would
emerge regardless in addition to all of
that in this tournament we managed to
give Satan his own little mini Story We
allotted for Vegeta to still fall prey
to Bobby's magic for the same reasons he
does so in the main story and allowed
for the rest of the series to
potentially play out as it does normally
but we're not perfect and we'll probably
see lots of issues with this as soon as
we hit upload with that said we
encourage all who have suggestions to
leave them in the comments down below
despite being tougher than we
anticipated this was still a very
enjoyable video to write so be sure to
leave a like And subscribe if you want
to see more and if you want to support
this channel even more feel free to
contribute any amount you see fit to our
patreon but on that note we're going to
end it here as always I've been totally
nutmarc and thank you all so much for
watching
[Music]